hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll and
here at mindscape we are members of what
back in my day was referred to as the
reality-based community we believe that
there is a reality out there there's a
real world you don't get to pick
reality at the fundamental level at
least but of course we all know that
when we examine reality when we talk
about it when we carve it up when we
turn it into useful little person-sized
chunks there's a lot of human choice
that goes into how we describe reality
sometimes this is a very trivial thing
right you can describe reality at the
level of particles and fields where you
describe the reality of the level of
atoms and molecules all the way up to
organisms and societies and what have
you
i would argue i know i'm an extremist on
this not everyone agrees i think that
even at the level of particles and
fields we human beings are making
choices to talk about reality in a
certain way the real way of talking
about reality is as a single wave
function in hilbert space but anyway
that's an extremist point of view like i
said
in physics in science more generally
these ways that we carve up reality to
talk about them are more or less fixed
by the data by our desire to fit our
experience into some framework which we
call a theory of physics or something
like that a theory of some other kind of
science but as you go up and up and up
toward the human level as you become
more and more macroscopic
we end up making more more choices about
how to describe reality once you get to
the level of
people in societies and countries and
governments then you're making things up
right and left we make up things like
rights and privileges and laws right
even when we describe the people around
us we make up categories categories of
race or gender or class
which is fine we need these categories
they help us analyze the world there's
no choice about it the problem is that
two problems actually one problem is
sometimes we begin to think that the
ways that we have chosen to conveniently
divide up the world are just as fixed by
the facts as electrons and protons are
fixed by the facts we under emphasize or
downgrade the extent to which we are
making choices that didn't need to be
that way and the second problem is that
sometimes not only do we think that our
categories are
kind of immutable but we give them a
kind of normative advantage we say
they're the right way to be it's not
just as the only way to be or the
descriptively correct way to be but it's
good to be that way these are natural
things to fall into but there are also
things to resist a little bit if we want
to be as accurate and as careful as we
can in thinking about reality so the way
that we analyze this idea that we human
beings make choices in carving up
reality is known as the social
construction of reality or the social
construction of different categories or
different ideas or different concepts
that we use to think about reality and
so part of this social construction idea
is that the ideas we make up to
construct our picture of reality aren't
arbitrary right just because you say an
idea is socially constructed doesn't
mean it has no relationship
to the real world of immutable
scientific stuff but that relationship
deserves examination parts of it might
be fixed parts of it might be up for
grabs maybe we can even improve some
parts of it so today's guest is sally
haslinger who is a well-known philosophy
professor at mit who is an expert on
exactly this idea of the social
construction of reality you know she's a
professor at mit she jokes in the
podcast she cares about technology
science things like that not saying that
it's all up for grabs but really
interrogating the way that we human
beings have made choices about how to
describe
different kinds different aspects of
reality we'll get into the obvious ones
uh race and sex are two of the very very
obvious ones or gender i should say um
and then there's the question that
immediately arises what should our
attitudes be toward thinking about this
like how can we prevent ourselves from
falling into the trap
of taking the categories that we invent
as given to us objectively by nature and
that gets into the area known as
critical theory critical theory in the
context of critical race theory has been
in the news recently
for all the wrong reasons and we're not
really going to talk about that but the
more general picture of critical theory
is just examining the presuppositions
that we inevitably have when we examine
culture and society looking for the
hidden assumptions that lead us maybe
down the wrong path and trying to make
the world a better place that's the role
of critical theory and so i think this
is a very fair discussion i don't always
agree with everything i never do but i
think this is going to be a good
introduction to these kinds of ideas
especially if you're instantly skeptical
okay i think that sally does a very good
job of laying the groundwork as to why
you would think in this particular kind
of way whether or not you end up
thinking it's the best way of going
occasional reminders that uh here at the
podcast we have a website you can check
out preposterousuniverse.com
not only are there show notes with links
for all the different episodes but you
have complete transcripts so if you're
more of a reading type person than
listening type person all the words are
there on the website perfectly
searchable you can find out who was the
person who was talking about synthetic
biology etc it's all there and if you
want to support mindscape you can go to
patreon we have a patreon at patreon.com
sean m carroll you can sign up to give a
dollar per episode and that lets you
participate in the ask me anything
episodes and so forth more generally
there's lots of ways to support
mindscape you know you can go leave good
reviews on
itunes or whatever they call it these
days apple music i don't know where you
get your podcasts apple podcasts
wherever you get your podcast you can
leave good reviews spread the word we
want everyone in the world to be
listening to mindscape that's the
ultimate goal right so let's go
[Music]
sally haslinger welcome to the mindscape
podcast
great to be here thanks for inviting me
you know we've been without much
planning on my part uh i've been having
a few episodes where you talk about
reality what is what is real in
different ways in very different ways
the very first podcast of the year is
with jodie azuni who talks about whether
mathematical objects are real uh the
second podcast was david reich the
geneticist from harvard who when i asked
him you know our species real he's like
ah it's a philosophical question i don't
want to talk about that
um but so i think maybe we're somewhere
in between here today but we're the
angle is the social construction
of reality and
as someone who is a physicist myself you
know somewhat sympathetic to the idea
but there's clearly a whole bunch of
questions that come up when you just say
that phrase so i figured we should just
start
by getting some ideas on the table i
mean
when you say the social construction of
reality in some sense just what do you
have in mind but in particular
um is that to say
[Music]
how close is that to a we can construct
whatever we want anything goes kind of
thing or are you constrained by the
reality as we scientists know it for
example that's a great set of questions
so i like to distinguish two senses of
social construction one sense of social
construction is just causal construction
so we there are lots of artifacts in the
world they're made by people um they're
sometimes made by an individual but
they're sometimes made by groups of
individuals or societies or such so a
highway right right um you might want to
say well that was produced by
you know there was a legislator
legislature that um earmarked money to
make the highway and then there were
people who were
contracted to build it and whatever and
a highway is a social construction now
that's not the standard way of using
social construction
but social construction does have a
causal component and one way of thinking
about it is that or some one form of
social construction has a causal
component
so if you think about
how
my body is shaped
it is shaped in part because of the
the way that the chromosomes have have
uh take
inform different parts of matter to sort
of build a body that's of a human shape
but it's also shaped by
um what i do what i eat how much i work
out and those sorts of things and those
sorts of things how much of that i do
is affected in part by gender norms
norms about appropriate appearances for
women
about my moral beliefs about not eating
meat or animal products and so there's a
way and we could say that my body is at
least partly socially constructed in the
sense that those social norms and
beliefs have played a causal role
in shaping my body okay so that's a
that's so i'm inclined to think of my
body as both a biological phenomenon
it's a biological entity but it's also
kind of a social entity as well
because it has been shaped very much by
choices that i have made in response to
my social context
so there's a kind of so a causal
conception of social construction there
but i also think that there's a
different that's non-causal sense of
construction but it looked like you had
a question about about the causal stuff
well well yeah because i don't want to
be
too
have too much i mean
maybe i should or should not say what i
want but i i i want to make clear how
weak or strong the notion of social
construction is i mean everyone will
agree that your body is socially
influenced by the exact factors that you
mentioned that's a little bit weaker
maybe than constructed and so what is
the difference there yes
yes well i do think that there's a use
of the term social construction
where it just means influenced that
there's a there's a
significant social influence on
on the body or on the world in a way
that
sort of goes through our social norms
and practices and it doesn't say that it
makes it from scratch right nobody is
saying that it makes it from scratch
um but think of it this way um a statue
isn't made from scratch either a statue
comes into existence it's made of clay
it is shaped in a certain way and
becomes a statue and similarly you know
my body you might think of there's the
clay and that it was shaped in various
ways and it came to be
something more statue-like in the sense
that it is composed of the biological
entity the animal but it is not just
that biological entity it is something
more than that like the statue is more
than just the clay and so i think that
that that sense of composition
is important in some of the senses of
social construction that you come to
you're not going to say oh the statue
came to be from nothing
you know because you know it came to be
from
the effects
of
an artist who was also influenced by a
social context on a material substrate
and so my body there's a material
substrate there a material substrate
like the clay or the marble
has causal you know potentialities that
are not up to me but among the
potentialities that it has is to respond
to what other people
say or think or demand or the kinds of
punishments that they may impose on me
if i don't conform to certain things and
so those potentialities just like the
clay has a potentiality
to um take to molding in a certain way
by
not just its environment but by the
artist so my body has a potentiality to
be molded by me in response to the
social context and so i'm kind of
thinking about just as you know you
knock the statue off the table and it
falls to the floor by virtue of its
physical properties
not by virtue of its aesthetic
properties
when someone comes in and sees it they
respond to it as something beautiful by
virtue of its aesthetic properties that
are go oh that are over and above its
mere physical properties so it sounds
like in this sense of social
construction uh various aspects of a
body or a person or whatever are
the ones that are socially constructed
and for obvious reasons that seems very
important um
but i know there are people out there
who will tell me that quarks and leptons
and atoms and particles are socially
constructed and that doesn't seem to
follow for what you just said
no no and i'm not i would like to say
that not everything is socially
constructed
um that there are plenty of things in
the world that aren't socially
constructed and drawing
you know some kind of distinction
between those that are and those that
aren't as tricky and difficult and
controversial but i think it it falls
somewhere out there now there is another
so ian hacking used to talk about the
social construction of quirks and things
like that but he wanted to distinguish
the social construction of things from
the social construction of object of
concepts
so concepts all concepts are socially
constructed they come to us through
language they come to us through
our interactions with other people you
know you're a baby you grow up you learn
the concepts you learn because those are
the ones that are made available to you
in your social media now i'm chomsky and
enough to think that there's a that
we're pre-wired to pick up certain
concepts and not others
but but it's i'm inclined to think that
you know it's the concept the thing that
the mental entity if there is one um is
a social construct but the thing it
corresponds to in the world isn't
necessarily a social construct okay but
there are just not to only mention your
views but those of others there's sort
of a spectrum of strength of this idea
of social construction where some people
are going to put it all in the mind
right and but you're but you're very
happy to say there are things out there
in the world and we're we're
talking about the the powers and impacts
they have on the world as a feature of
being in part socially constructed
yeah yeah okay and it's like i mean so
some people even in philosophy will say
that there isn't a new thing the statue
there's just the lump of clay that is
statue shaped and so some people will
want to say there's not a new thing
the
the social body over and above the
biological body but some people want to
say no there's there's the biological
body and then there's the kind of social
body just like the statue in the clay
and i think that's
that's a a matter of some controversy in
philosophy but i don't think it matters
for the ordinary person okay good and i
think i did uh interrupt you with a
question there but you were maybe going
on to other versions of social
construction beyond the causal yes great
yes and always interrupt me i love it um
so in addition to causal construction i
think there is something that i call
constitutive construction
and so constitutive construction is when
you have a category
that is defined in part
by reference to
social phenomena so take the category of
a spouse
now
i am a spouse
and to be a spouse is to stand in a
relationship to another person and the
state right because we are legally
leaders
and and that is a social category it is
not a natural category it's a social
category
so sometimes what what philosophers will
say is that the category of wife
is socially constructed
meaning
it's not a category in nature so to
speak it's a category in our social
world but that doesn't mean it's not
real so this comes back to that issue so
i'm a realist about almost everything
and so um and so to say that a category
is socially constructed
some people will say is to say it's an
illusion i say no it's not necessarily
you know spouses aren't an illusion
spouses are real we have powers by
virtue of being spouses right right we
have social powers and legal powers etc
by virtue but it's not as if um
uh we want to say well yeah i am
i am a spouse because of some
uh
well i am a spouse because of some
causal process of going to the justice
of the peace and being married and
something like that but it's different
to say that what it is to be a spouse
is to stand in these social relations
and that's constitutive construction as
opposed to causal construction okay i
mean they're clearly closely related to
each other right i mean they're gonna
yes bounce back and forth and actually
this is this is very sympathetic to
uh stuff that i talked about in my book
the big picture where i talk about
different layers of reality and and
attaching reality to all of the
different stories that we can tell
accurately about the world and so the
social world is where it gets tricky
right like i always like to say i'm a
physicist because it's easy
because it's fairly simple to pinpoint
what what happens and what doesn't
whereas the social world very messy um
and so what then is the
is the power of mentioning or pointing
out or highlighting the social
construction of these things as opposed
to just you know choosing a theoretical
vocabulary to talk about certain parts
of the world
yeah
well i do think that the choice of
phil's of theoretical vocabulary is
important but one of the reasons why
people have
put a lot of energy into saying
something like gender or race etc is
socially constructed
is that it is a strategy
for
certain
social formations
to make it seem as though
gender or race or certain other
categories are determined by nature
and are are thereby
immutable
inevitable
etc etc and so those people who are
interested in saying that they're
socially constructed
is to say
no we played at least a major role
in
creating
the things that fall in those categories
i like the statue like that we created
them like we create a statue but also
that some of the categories themselves
are social categories they're not
natural categories okay so
some people would say this is
controversial but sex might be a natural
category
but gender is not a natural category and
so people assume that given your sex you
will have a certain gender
because it's
biologically determined that if you have
that sex you will have that gender but
other people want to say no no no no
that that that assumption of of
biological determination um is false
good so if i can try to rephrase that
you can tell me if i'm on the right
track the there's a usefulness in
highlighting the social constructedness
of things because it helps us divide
that which is just given to us by nature
from that which we have
consciously or unconsciously assigned as
properties to these categories
yeah that's that's it now i do think
that it's a mistake to assume that
because something is social it's easily
changeable
or more easily changeable than the
natural world i mean i'm in a techno you
know i'm at mit so i i'm all about
technology i believe in technology
technology is a wonderful way to change
the world and change the the
natural facts of the world um but and
the social is much harder to change
actually i think uh so
although
um there are feminists who disagree with
me i think that one of the greatest
advances for women's liberation is the
birth control pill right it's a piece of
technology technology and it uh it meant
that women could make their own choices
about their reproductive uh
possibilities in out of the moment in
the privacy of their you know
own
uh private lives right something like
that without having to negotiate with
anybody about what was happening and i
think that was a a huge advance but it
was something that just changed our
reproductive biology so to speak um it
let me let me just this that may or may
not be a useful analogy or comparison
but in physics um we certainly have
situations where the same exact physical
phenomena can be described in different
theoretical vocabularies right
um different formulations of classical
mechanics or quantum mechanics or
whatever so there's both
what happens in some purportedly
objective sense and how we talk about
what happens which is obviously a choice
that we make is that close to the
relationship we have between let's say
sex and gender
so
i don't think so because
i think
um
we're not talking about the same thing
when we're talking about sex and gender
yeah okay that's right um
and so it's not just a matter of
different vocabularies so maybe let me
go back a little bit to
um one of the early
introductions of the notion of gender in
the academy
um
so
feminist historians
were interested in thinking about
the different ways
over time and across culture
that
um people of a particular sex live their
lives
right so females
they don't always
you know live the same sort of life
depending on what culture you're in
there are many different norms there are
many different senses of themselves and
identities there are many different
expectations
and so they wanted a way to think about
um not just the underlying sex but the
set of assumptions
that shaped women's lives and that women
then conform to
and this so the slogan uh was well
uh gender is the social meaning of sex
allowing that the same sex across time
and place could have very different
social meanings
and so the social meaning of a woman
in the 21st century united states is
very different than the social meaning
of woman in
you know china in the third century
something like that and so that was the
idea of trying to pick up the notion of
gender and it was important to this um
uh kind of disruptive
attempt because in every case you find
in across history and across culture
that the the
background cultural assumption is that
this is the way women are naturally this
is the way women ought to be this is the
way that whatever but historians were
saying well how could that be you know
if it varies so tremendously across
place and time it's certainly not
natural um that women you know do this
or that or the other thing so that's how
the notion of gender emerged as the
social meaning of sex allowing this
tremendous variation
and also
the fact that that our bodies and our
ways of life and our self-identities and
all of that are being influenced by the
history and the culture that we're part
of i mean you said a lot of that in the
past tense is that because it's been
accomplished or do you still agree with
it now
so i think so the distinction between
sex and gender is is controversial many
people don't like to draw it because
they think that it presupposes that
there is this given of sex
you know the sex binary
and
and so i think that there's a different
sense in which we might want to say
that the the binary the sex binary is
not given
in the sense that there's a large
spectrum um from
uh
people with female body parts and people
with male body parts and we can draw
different
you know lines along that spectrum um
there's intersex people there's uh
people who
uh
in different cultures um don't count as
either one or the other not because
they're intersexed but because of other
factors about their their lives and how
you define sex is also socially variable
so so that's something that makes the
sex gender distinction a little bit more
controversial
because if you're just saying well sex
is given and then gender is the social
meaning of that
it gets more complicated than that very
quickly because you want to say well
sex is sort of
you know socially
categorized too
and then there's gender on top of that
um but i think that there's still a
distinction worth making
between the divisions of people based on
their body parts and the divisions of
people based on the meaning of those
body parts yeah okay and that i think
gender is
the distinctions between people based on
the perceived or imagined
body parts that they have and and what
they mean in a particular culture that
does make perfect sense to me there is
something biological and we are allowed
to talk about that and classify it and
it would be overly simplistic to make it
a binary but there are still facts of
the matter about what your chromosomes
are what your anatomy is and there's a
separate set of questions about social
roles and expectations and how we dress
and behave in those things right is that
roughly the sex gender that's roughly
the idea and i i mean i
maybe
um on a certain end of a spectrum
because i believe that actually
not paying attention to different
reproductive functions
would be a a potential source of
injustice
because i do think that females
play a substantially different role in
reproduction um
uh that fertile females in particular
and
and that should be taken into account by
a society that there's there is a social
meaning of pregnancy
pregnancy produces
in the good cases the next generation
this is something that's socially
incredibly important and not and and you
know rape and sexual violence um happen
to both men and women but they ha it has
different consequences for males and
females potentially um and so i think
that these these biological differences
can't be just
ignored um if we're going to achieve
justice well so i think that yeah this
is certainly bringing up exactly where
the rubber hits the road in terms of
these questions because
we
i mean basically if i have the picture
right
in a non-reflective way we created these
social categories and they were closely
related but not the same as sort of
scientific categories and now we're
being a little bit more reflective about
it and for good reasons as we'll get to
later the other sort of social justice
reasons to try to do this we want to
make the world a better place but it's
hard because the vocabulary isn't there
and the expectations are a little weird
and you know so i mean you're using
words like male and female
etcetera what do these words mean
how should we go about this project we
need to invent completely new words i
mean i know in discourse about trans
people there is a discussion of the
extent to which we should just say trans
women are women full stop right yes
and i see the attraction of that in
terms of giving them the rights and
expectations that women have
there are obviously biological
differences or whatever and so how do
you even talk about that like what is
what is the what is the way in which
this
separation of the socially constructed
parts versus the natural or scientific
parts i'm not quite sure what to call
the other parts
totally no this is this is what we're
struggling with i mean both
theoretically and culturally i think
we're struggling with so
since you know for the past 30 years or
so
since this introduction in the academy
of a notion of gender as the social
meaning of sex
people have um sort of regimented the
language to suggest that we use male and
female for sex okay and man and woman
for gender okay now
now that's uh
it doesn't always work i mean i myself
even talked about men and women what i
was really talking about males and
females because in ordinary discourse
and i'm trying to speak
non-theoretically so in ordinary
discourse you know we use men and women
more than male and female so it's it is
very tricky to communicate and there are
and and when you use male and female
there's this temptation to reinforce the
binary because what's the other sexes
like what do we want to call we haven't
even in you know sort of culturally
theoretically decided how many sexes we
want there to be or think that there are
and so some people are resistant to you
know male and female as the sexes
okay because that already reifies the
binary
and then when you're starting to talk
about
about genders you don't want to assume
that genders are just
the social meanings of male and female
because there might be the social
meanings of all different other kinds of
categories so you i mean to take it so
eunuchs are an example an interesting
example right that they they have a
different body type not naturally but by
virtue of um surgical intervention and
there's a different social meaning
associated with them
and so sometimes people have thought
well what we
what we need to do is look historically
at these different formations and social
formations that offer us examples of
different
bodies and different
different meanings of those different
kinds of bodies
and so some people
have looked to the two-spirit tradition
in native american cultures
and suggested that there are
um
uh different genders there
and sort of left it a bit open about how
we want to
uh
categorize sex in contexts like that and
and you know there's a kind of
openness and sort of ongoing exploration
and political contestation
over that i mean i guess if that makes
sense yeah no that makes perfect sense
and maybe um
the answer to my next question was
implicit in the sentence you just said
but i was going to say
okay now that we have this improved
understanding of these distinctions
what do we do with it i mean maybe that
what we do with it is just talk about it
in a slightly more clear rigorous way
than we used to when we were just taking
things for granted
yes i do think that
clear and clarity and rigor is a good
thing but there's also
um politics
because i've noticed yes
[Laughter]
because there are some people who
do not want to allow that trans women
are women
because
our
social facilities such as bathrooms or
our laws around marriage
etc
are are organized around men and women
and
and because of that
the rights and privileges that
individuals have by virtue of being men
or women
are connected historically to body type
yeah
and so when you start saying well
a woman is just a gender and it's not
necessarily connected to a body type
that suddenly changes a set of
uh rights and privileges
and obligations that people have
by virtue of well by virtue of what i
mean is it by virtue of their identity
is it by virtue of their bodies is it by
virtue of what and that becomes
immediately quite political i do want to
get back to that but it reminds me of an
analogy that i came up with while
reading some of your things but then i
think that i noticed that you came up
with the same analogy which is to
money
you know money is a social construction
we invented it but there's a whole bunch
of people out there who
have a you know a strong feeling that
money should be more tangible than it
really is and they want to you know go
on the gold standard they want to they
want to feel secure that they could hand
in some dollars and get something
tangible back whereas in the actual
current system it is just entirely
socially constructed it's just what we
agree to do when you give us money and
is that sort of
search or or desire for certainty and
foundationalism part of the thing you're
up against when you when you emphasize
the social construction of things
i mean that's of
an interesting
analogy and i think that there's a lot
to it but
given what we were talking about before
that there are different bodies that
have different potentialities
it isn't just like money right because
you can't
make it the case that someone can get
pregnant
um just by saying so or categorize the
categorizing them as of of a certain
kind you know by how we think you know
that there are that they're all
vulnerabilities
that individual bodies have
that we should be respectful of and
attentive to um but how to do that
is part of what's at issue in the
political in the political landscape
okay how do we want to be attentive to
and also to history that there are
spaces where women have felt safe
from sexual predation
where females have felt safe from sexual
predation and what does it mean now to
make those spaces open to males
where
being a male
brings with it certain physical
potentialities
that are already sort of have a meaning
in our society and so that becomes
highly problematic so there's
women wanting safe spaces
but
and so they associate threat with a
certain body type
but
it may not be that that body type brings
with it a threat but that has it already
has its social meaning in place over
time over history and people can feel
threat even if there isn't a threat um
and so
and they want a safe place from feeling
threatened yeah yeah right so
so i think that you you've done the you
know uh perfect philosopher thing in
stating the problem in wonderful clarity
and and comprehensiveness but so what's
the answer
is there i mean how or even if we can't
just give the answer in simple terms how
do we
address a question like that once you've
said you know okay
who gets to go into which restroom is
entirely socially constructed i mean
which doesn't as you've correctly said
which doesn't mean it's divorced from
physical facts but it's is nevertheless
a constructed fact okay um what are our
guidelines what are the principles that
we use to make better decisions about
those questions it's not easy right
it's not easy no i i love to tell any uh
an anecdote of a i i am a subscriber to
a local theater uh central square
theater and um
and before the pandemic they converted
all of the restrooms to
uh gender-neutral restrooms all gender
restrooms
and so
i remember the first time going in there
shortly after this happened
and we were all going yeah great gender
all gender restrooms great and then but
there were some restrooms that had
urinals and some that didn't but they
had put cubicles around the urinals and
so it was my turn i was waiting in line
i went in and there i went into a
cubicle and it had a urinal and i said
oh sorry i need to wait would someone
else like to use this cubicle or
whatever and someone else went in and
didn't close the door and i said excuse
me but i know you're not used to closing
the door but please close the door and
so we were kind of navigating in this
space
about how what were the norms because we
don't have norms for public restrooms
that are all
gender restrooms and so but it was an
interesting thing and now over years now
it's opened up again after the pandemic
and i go in there and there's a lot more
interesting signage that makes it clear
you know okay this has
you know this one has two urinals in it
if you need them you know and there's a
little marker about which one have the
urinals and which one don't have the
urinal so you're not sort of waiting to
go into one that you don't you can't use
or something like that so but i love
that period of
exploration to sort of see how the norms
sort of made themselves because we had
to figure it out and we had to figure it
out respectfully and we had to figure it
out together how to make it happen so i
think that in small contexts
that can happen where you likes
coordination can ery arise with people
trying to solve a problem
but it's much more complicated when
we're thinking nationally or
in terms of laws or something like this
this was a group of people who are
already happy to participate in that
negotiation
yeah it could work and so i think that
there are a couple of things that are
important one is to be sensitive to
the empirical facts so
in massachusetts
once
um gender identity was made more
flexible so that um
you know uh trans women were women and
trans men were men
and so they were permitted to go into
restrooms
there was an open question
about whether there would be an increase
in violence or whether people would be
um
be more challenged in finding restrooms
that they felt comfortable in and safe
in
and it turned out there in the period of
time when this was sort of a trial um
there were was no increase in violence
in restrooms and there there weren't
complaints um that were lodged i don't
know if
if there might have been complaints that
were not formally made but there were no
formal complaints and so then it was
ratified to continue
um
but there still are people who make the
claim
that
allowing trans women into women's
restrooms makes cis women unsafe
but there's an empirical question here
um about whether it does or not and so
one first sort of
one one initial
stab at how we should proceed
is that we need to get empirical data we
need to get empirical evidence about uh
what what works and what doesn't work um
but that's not everything because i do
think that there are people who for one
reason or another
do feel vulnerable um
because of their own history or because
of their cultural uh
understandings and expectations
and so i i think that nowadays in most
um
uh malls and airports in the us
um you have family bathrooms um you have
single stall so to speak you know
single occupancy restrooms they're
called or family restrooms where someone
who is not comfortable going in to one
or the other has an option to go in it
may take longer because there may be
more of a wait but women are used to
waiting yeah
it's about time the rest of the world
so i think that there may be
possibilities of
both allowing trans women
access to what cis women have access to
while also providing spaces for people
who are less comfortable with that
option um where they might feel safer i
mean i like the answer because if if i'm
interpreting what i'm hearing correctly
uh rather than
sitting back in our armchairs and
reflecting on how the way the world
should be uh faced with this realization
that certain things are socially
constructed and maybe not in the ideal
way it's more about a social practice
and trying things out and being a good
empiricist and seeing what works
totally totally that's all that's what
i'm all about and and because it's about
coordination
and and you
efforts to impose
coordinate you know terms of
coordination on groups of people
um
sometimes works but often doesn't work
because it's not sufficiently sensitive
to
the needs of the people who are
coordinating and the the histories and
the et cetera et cetera and so you've
got to see
what's you got to use the empirical you
know information that you can get to see
what's going to work well one empirical
question is just how willing people are
to let terms be redefined i mean i think
a good example of a success story is
same-sex marriage where some people
would have just not defined that as part
of marriage and the world parts of the
world anyway have more or less come on
board with uh defining it to include
same-sex couples um
is i mean how
how much do you as a philosopher have to
think about this practical problem of
getting people to go along with the
program how malleable are these socially
constructed terms
yeah i think that's a that's an
excellent question and
um i think that the job of a philosopher
is to make proposals um in the context
of a social movement so i don't think
it's our job to sit at a desk
and
make up some
you know new way of thinking and
speaking about things but to be
responsive to problems that have emerged
on the ground where coordination is not
working
and to work with those people on the
ground to to see
how we might redescribe the situation in
a way that could be paradigm shifting
right that could give you whoa a whole
new way of looking at this i mean that's
what one of the things that philosophers
can be good at is sort of go well
let's break that open and then think
about it this way but you can't go too
far because people are not going to go
too far too fast right so you've got to
kind of but i'm very committed to
working on the ground as part of a
movement to see if there are ways to do
this that can shift perspectives now
you're not going to get everybody to buy
in for all all different kinds of
reasons
but i think part of the job of a social
movement is to provide incentives to do
so um incentives to
[Music]
go along with the pac um because we're
coordinating and we're doing we're doing
it fine and we're happy to do it and if
you don't want to be part of it
you know okay
you can try and do it your own way but
you're going to miss us because we're
valuable and we're important and you're
going to want to do it with us right
some that's an oversimplification
obviously but the social movement is
trying to
change the way we do things
and people are very highly incentivized
to do what we do right now the problem
is when you get polarization
they say oh but we're not part of your
we anymore
and i think that's a bit where we are on
a number of different issues now so a
question might be how do you
overcome polarization
and i think that sometimes
there's an assumption that well you just
use the law right but the law is not a
simple solution i mean as we can see
from you know racial integration it it
it
blew back on itself very badly um and
you know that's what generated the civil
rights movement is after brown b board
of education and people were not going
to integrate their schools um you know
in in some states in virginia i think it
was um they shut down this some of the
school districts the public school
districts because they just made it all
private so that they didn't have to
integrate so there are lots of
strategies for for a
a community to resist legal pressures
because their cultural norms and their
way of life and their
self-understandings
just can't tolerate that that change and
they're not going to put up with the
imposition
of of a new form of life
and so then the question is and so then
what happened is the civil rights
movement moved in it made some progress
but we're still faced with um racial
segregation um we're still struggling
with that um so i don't think there's a
you know
moving from from black to
african-american it was a good idea but
it didn't solve the problem so language
itself
you know i'm not sure how how good an
idea was but at the moment it seemed
like a good idea but you know just
changing the language does not solve our
it's not enough just changing the law
does not solve our problems and that's
where i wanted to move next into you
know
slightly more treacherous territory in
some sense because
i'm betting that everyone listening to
the podcast almost everyone is happy
with same-sex marriage
and even those who objected to it you
know
they they thought it was unnatural it
didn't fit but
it was a hard case for them to make that
they were really being inconvenienced by
this shift whereas when it comes to
gender or race now we have a situation
where there's a group that is benefiting
from the socially constructed categories
and another group that is being
disadvantaged and that's a harder thing
to change maybe and i know that maybe
this is the time to talk about um
what i i think is a claim that you've
made about how the fact that men are on
top and women are on the bottom is an
integral part of what we mean in the
socially constructed language of uh men
and women
yeah
so
um
i
in the period where we were trying to
figure out what gender is and we had the
slogan
um gender is the social meaning of sex
it started to seem as though
oh well there is and we use the term
woman for
you know the the social meaning of the
female sex it suddenly sounds like well
women is not a unified category the
whole idea was that they're all
different ways of being women and
there's different social meanings etc
etc
and social meanings across class and
across race and across whatever and so
it started to seem that it was such a
heterogeneous category
this social meaning of sex or the social
meaning of femaleness
that that we were going to lose the idea
of women how do you fight for the rights
of women if you can't agree on what
women are
if you ca exactly and i can remember a
t-shirt that i bought that said i'll be
post-feminist in the post-patriarchy
because
people were suggesting that there was no
no way to sustain a feminist movement if
there are no women and there are no
women in general right there's
there's
there's we all are in these multiple
categories and our social lives are
dictated by so many things
so
it was part of my project to think about
well what would the feminist
what can a feminist movement really
focus on
when they're focusing on the rights of
women or the well-being of women or
the emancipation of women etc
and it struck me that
the that what i care about at least
is
is fighting for those people
who are interpreted to have a certain
reproductive function
interpreted to
be capable of menstruation and pregnancy
capable of uh growing breasts etc um i'm
sorry when i'm fighting you disappeared
for like two seconds there you said okay
you're fighting for people who are
interpreted to have
okay got it so
so
let's put it this way people
people's bodies are interpreted
as male or female whether they are male
or female or not
right
and so and that has been the case
forever right there are people who
have male bodies but live as women and
people who have female bodies and live
as men but it seems to me that what i
was most concerned with when i was you
know thinking as a feminist
was
the ways in which people's bodies are
interpreted as female
ends up having a consequence for what
opportunities they have what resources
they have etc and those resources and
opportunities are
you know
disadvantaged compared to those whose
bodies are interpreted as male right so
i know that's a lot to try and get
across but the basic idea is it's it's
about
how
the interpretation of your body
plays a role
in in the justice
of your opportunities and and your life
right those sorts of things and so and i
wanted it to be the k i wanted to be the
case that those
those interpretations don't dictate
you know what your possibilities are in
life that's a very simple you know i
think i hope all of your listeners will
think that that's a good idea
how my body is interpreted as male or
female shouldn't dictate what my
opportunities are and what how much i
make or what i can so i can love i mean
part of my job as the podcast host is to
imagine the contrary so i mean let's
imagine the best version of the contrary
opinion where you say look uh males and
females are different they have certain
um things they're good at certain roles
that they're good at playing let's not
fight that let's just uh
let that difference exist and celebrate
it and
allow social roles to reflect that i
don't believe that but you know that
would be the i think yeah that sounds
not completely crazy if you didn't know
anything about the real world
well you know one of the things john
stuart mills said in his subjection of
women the book the subjection of women
is that
um
we have never
uh treated women as equals
we have never given them the opportunity
to do what they wanted to do
because we have told them what was right
and proper for them to do
so how could you possibly make a claim
based on the you know the evidence about
what the what women want or how they're
going to you know best live their lives
or what will make them most successful
because we don't have we don't have a
control right it's always been
dictated for women that they have a
particular role and for men that they
have a particular role
and so
so if we are good empiricists
we ought to step back from that and try
to see what happens and what we find
often
is that
a lot of men really hate
masculinity
and a lot of women really hate
femininity and that's they have to
struggle to conform to it and they are
much happier when they
you know don't have if a woman you know
is a physicist
she's
she's happy to be a physicist and to
tell her that her proper role
is in the home you know taking care of
babies she will look at you like you're
out of your mind and so and so i think
that
that's so when i'm thinking about
defining gender
the way i see it is um it continues to
be the social meaning of the the
reproductive body or the um
but what i i want to say is that men and
women as we have known them
as they have existed up until now
are the social meaning
of
the imagined or perceived female body
and the social the social meaning of
that with respect
to um oppression good privilege and
subordination so when we're fighting for
women we're fighting for those people
who have been subordinated because of
the way their body has been interpreted
now some people have thought well but
that's not what i mean by women
and i go yeah sure that's fine you know
i don't i'm not arguing that that that's
what we all have to mean in all contexts
whenever we use the term i'm using this
term in a particular way
that draws on this history of
gender being the social meaning of sex
of woman being the term that's used for
gender for understanding gender as a
category that's a primary concern for a
movement for the feminist movement and
how does this come to sort of practical
advice for our behavior as human beings
right i mean most people
like you say there's a lot of things
that are socially constructed not given
naturally and part of that is how we
dress how we cut our hair ways that code
us instantly as either masculine or
feminine is that
bad we resist that would it be more
emancipatory if we didn't have these
stereotypical behaviors or
are some of them benign and we can we
can enjoy them because some people do
enjoy them like i i i dress in a certain
way and it's totally like a guy
and yeah i i'm not that motivated to
change
yeah no i think that that's fine so so
my view is not we should all become
androgynous
but it's that the
that having long hair and breasts and
wearing a dress should not have
consequences
for you in terms of your pay in terms of
your career opportunities in terms of
you know other things that you might
want to do with your life you shouldn't
be assumed that you're going to be the
one to cook dinner or clean the house
and or if you're dressed in a coat and
tie that you're the kind of person who
wants to take care of the outside of the
house to mow the lawn and cut you know
do that sort of thing i mean there's
there's it's incredible the detail
of gender norms about what you're
supposed to do etc um given your body
type and you're thinking really
if you have a certain body type you cut
the lawn if you have another body type
you vacuum the house oh my god that's so
ridiculous you know but but it's to say
two things one is
to notice that that is contingent
it's historical and culturally and
historically specific
and that there's nothing natural about
it that you have to conform to
um
uh
if you want to yeah that's good
but that also it is often
um correlated with privilege and
disadvantage that these sorts of things
that people that men go out and women
stay home
and well what does it mean if you stay
home and and don't get to go out well
among other things you may not be able
to form a network of people
who you can turn to should things get
rough at home because you're confined to
the home or i mean i i know that's a
class assumption that women stay home
and and men go out because not in not
all classes or culture certainly is that
true but i'm trying to give an example
of how
even simple norms that look benign
can have serious consequences
for your well-being
and your your rights and your and your
flourishing
you know this yeah i this has brought up
a million things i want to ask all at
once let me just try to mention one of
them and you can respond you know i was
once invited to like go to a social kind
of i don't know it was an informal kind
of organization but it was only men only
men were allowed and it was like we're
not anti-woman we just want a space for
men to come and be men
and i said no i don't want to do that i
i kind of like hanging out with women it
seems like a very arbitrary kind of
dividing line i want to hang with
interesting people no matter what their
gender is and one of my friends who was
a member said you know in all sincerity
and he's you know very progressive
feminist guys like we're not in any way
you know it's not uh misogynist or
anything like that but it is a great
networking opportunity
and i said
but but that's the problem you're you
have a great networking opportunity from
which you're explicitly excluding half
the population that sounds wrong to me
yeah yeah well that's the kind of thing
i mean there's all kinds of ways in
which
um
i mean i actually think that women do
need to have certain spaces for
self-segregation
in order to
you know have conversations about
i mean part of the reason is that
because
we're
because both men and women are expected
to
have certain desires and certain
preferences and certain talents and
certain forms of life
when you don't it's very tempting to
think that there's something wrong with
you
that you are to blame because it's
natural so you must be abnormal or
unnatural or something like that and
when you meet with others
um who are in a similar situation and
you find out oh you don't like to do
that either you're not good at that
either your husband acts that way too
then what happens is that you begin to
see it's not necessarily all your fault
that there's a structural problem here
there's a more systematic problem here
and that is the beginning of
consciousness raising good that's a
crucial movement so it could be that for
men getting together
what they realize there's one thing is i
hate being masculine i don't like
football or you know whatever yeah i'm
i'm stereotyping obviously but i don't
want to you know be the one to
make the money i want to be the one to
take care of the child or
again stereotyping and and sort of using
ancient history um
but it's but it's a way that you can
begin to notice
these structural
patterns
that are not
good for everybody yeah they're good for
some people but they're not good for
everybody and then you can begin to
identify what needs to change so let me
once again try to rephrase and state
back and and you can correct my
misimpressions but it sounds like and
i might get this wrong just because i
already believe it so maybe i'm not
hearing the deep the subtleties but it
sounds like look if in a particular
household that has a couple that one man
and one woman if the woman wants to be
the one who does all the cooking and the
man wants to be the one who mows the
lawn
that's fine and even if in 90 of such
households that's the division of labor
that's fine as long as number one in the
ten percent where the woman wants to mow
the lawn and the man wants to do the
cooking that's also fine and number two
we're sure that this purportedly
innocent division of labor is not
actually smuggling in some uh inequity
somehow
yeah yeah and that second part is also
really important because it's not just
oh we're just all going to sort of
you know mix and match our happy gender
categories and such like that
because we have to be super attentive to
the possibility
that
the mixing and matching of norms and and
features of people
um
it it creates
it creates inequities and some of even
the benign ones
when you collect them there's a kind of
uh
a spiraling effect or a kind of
accumulation
of pro small privileges can
make a big privilege right and you want
to be very sensitive to when that
happens and how that happens i don't
know if you're familiar with her work
but i did a great podcast with kailyn
o'connor um oh i love kailyn yeah she's
amazing and she she uses game theory to
show how you could start from a
purportedly neutral situation and the
inequities come about because someone's
going to win someone's going to lose it
makes perfect sense yeah and then you
get more bargaining power
a little bit more bargaining power each
time right and then you get a lot more
bargaining power and that's exactly and
then you define it as natural so
everyone everyone goes along right
exactly okay so let me then this is
going to be a little bit of shift of
gears but i think that there's some
continuity here um because we've
smuggled in notions of what would be
just what would be better what would be
an improvement on society so where did
those come from i know that a lot of
your work you know we've talked about
social constructive reality but a lot of
your work has also done
dealt with
critical theory making the world a
better place uh
um
ideal theory is i guess maybe the best
place to start because i think that
uh the idea that we we make a better
world or we decide what the better world
would be by deciding first what the
perfect world would be
ideal world and then moving in that
direction that seems super duper natural
to me but i did a podcast with elizabeth
anderson and she began to talk me out of
it
by saying like how in the world would we
know what the ideal theory is we still
know that we could be better than we are
now
yeah so i'm i i think anderson is a big
influence in my work as well um
so i like to separate
um political theory from social theory
okay so political theory
is going to be concerned with
um the state and
state power to enforce
um human rights basically you know what
we want is
um first amendment you know whatever
bill of rights
and and uh thinking about mechanisms for
enforcement
but that doesn't really touch
a lot of our lives like how i mean and
it's part of liberalism and the the
liberal state is that you're supposed to
leave people absolutely free to form
their own conceptions of the good and to
live accordance with their conception of
the good
but
that scene makes it seem as though okay
you've got the state
and then you've got individuals who are
just making their own individual choices
about how to live right sounds good but
in fact
we live in societies and we participate
in social practices and social practices
reinforce certain
divisions of labor and gender norms and
all of these sorts of things and it's
very difficult for an individual by him
or herself to just say i'm not going to
do it that way right because
you might not get a job then or whatever
and then you won't support yourself etc
etc etc so we need to think about
about what are better and worse ways to
live
collectively
about
how are we going to organize ourselves
around family divisions of labor think
of something as simple like um the
scheduling of meals
so the scheduling of meals varies quite
a bit culture to culture
but it's kind of helpful to have
a
um an understood background assumption
about meals because after all kids go to
school they get meals in the middle of
the day i i was born in the north of
northern paris and moved to the south
and in the south the big meal was the
middle of the day at least and and it
was very weird i started gaining a lot
of weight because i would have a big
meal in the middle of the day at school
and then i'd come home and have a big
meal at night for dinner and and it was
like whoa this is a little it's
difficult right
you how
so are my family going to then start
having just a snack in them in the
evening when our traditions have been
big meals in the evening etc how do you
do this so there's and there's also
restaurant times you know if you want to
if you want to have lunch at 3 30 in the
afternoon in some places you know it's
kind of hard to find a good place to
have lunch at 3 30 in the afternoon so
we need to coordinate about that but
it's not going to make sense for the
state
to say okay everybody has to have
breakfast at eight and lunch at noon and
dinner at six this is the way to do it
so you've gotta find ways
to sort of manage this now that's a
trivial example but as you can imagine
it has a lot to do with who picks up the
kids at school right so does the does
the nurse call the mom or the dad well
back in the day before massachusetts had
marriage equality they always called the
mom and it was like i don't want you to
always call me naturally i work as hard
as my husband does and i don't you know
why don't you call him well it was
interesting that once marriage equality
came in they didn't indicate mother and
father
on the on the forms to go to school it's
parent one and parent two and so you
were supposed to put which parent should
be called first as parent one so we just
you know which was great but see there
is a change in a practice that had a
legal incentive
because of marriage equality but it
changed so many things about parenting
and who was going to be called who would
have to leave work how would they get
out of work etc etc so there were
changes there but subtle changes like
that can ripple
through a society because once
you know there's changes in
well i i switched from the the
the food the meals example to parenting
examples but what i'm trying to
emphasize is that
these
these small
differences in how we divide labor or
how we organize our time can make a
difference and can have elements of
justice in it as well because if women
are always the one being called away
from work
then they're going to be seen as much
less reliable and they're going to not
be able to have certain kinds of jobs
that you have to be available on call at
any moment etc etc like that so we have
to figure these out not just as a matter
of convenience but they can have justice
implications
as well
so then the issue is well how do you do
that do you design a society that's the
perfect society that has their meals at
the right time
that has their pickup from school
practices at the right no of course
that's ridiculous right so from my point
of view even if ideal theory makes sense
in the political domain which i'm not
saying it does in the domain of in the
social domain where i mostly work it
seems ridiculous right it seems it seems
as though you can't do it so what you
have to do
is analyze practices
that are currently in place
to determine
who's being advantaged and who's being
disadvantaged by those practices how
does that pattern that like kalyn
o'connor talks about how does that
bargaining power get reduced if you're
the one who always has to pick up the
kid right or always has to go home with
them when they're sick something like
how does that reduce your bargaining
power in various ways because you're not
bringing home the bacon and so etc etc
and so when you when you start to
analyze the practice you can then begin
to nudge people in different
to different standards different
expectations different rules for how it
is done and then again i think that's
what social movements do and sometimes
they use law
to make their to make that first move or
a tenth move or something like that but
sometimes they just you work in your own
school you know i'm kind of you it's
bottom-up kind of work you you go to the
principal and say can we have a new
policy where we do it this way rather
than that way
and then you start from there and then
the next school your neighbor they send
their kids to a different school and
they go oh that's so great i'm going to
see if my school will do that and then
suddenly etc i mean this this brings up
a digression which will take us back to
where we were before but is an important
one which is
let me give us slightly
better perhaps worry about this way of
thinking about things which is look life
is hard
getting through life is hard
knowing how to behave especially when
you're young when you're growing up and
you know as much as i agree that uh we
have a patriarchy and men get a lot of
benefits from the world life can be
really hard for young men in in the
modern world and when you are constantly
upending the expectations and changing
what they are
i think that there's there's reasons to
be sympathetic to worries that people
don't know what to do and that that
makes their lives harder
yeah
i have no that there's no question about
that and i i do think that
when you have a system of coordination
that works
things are going to get worse before
they get better if you try to change it
right because
you have to go into a certain period of
confusion and chaos
because you all you had was that old
system of coordination and now you're
not coordinating very well um it it also
i think
makes clear
that you can't just be a breaker right a
breaker of a system a disruptor
because
you have to have a different alternative
that people can begin to move toward
because otherwise they're not going to
move they're going to be stuck because
if they say okay you're going to break
it but then we have nothing else
or everybody's going in different
directions
that's not working for me you know so
they're gonna they're gonna retreat and
i think that's part of what's happening
now with polarization
some of it i mean some of it there's
lots of different explanations but some
of it is things are changing and things
are changing around gender and around
marriage and around race and around all
these things and they have been for a
long time and we've got to a kind of
tipping point possibly
and when you get to a tipping point and
you don't know what the other side looks
like
you don't want to go over the edge
right you're just going to go oh no no
sorry i'm backing up
i'm backing up you know fast because i'm
not going to go over that tipping point
because it looks it's the unknown it's
chaotic i don't know how to behave
everything i believed in is suddenly
false um and so i think that
that's a real problem with social change
and social change is often
you know ugly that's so it's a great way
of putting it it reminds me uh i just
keep bringing up old podcasts but one of
the very first ones i did was with
anthony pinn
who is a black atheist theologian at
rice university and he's very interested
in the question of why
blacks in the united states have such
low levels of atheism among them and he
actually grew up as a childhood preacher
and he says look it's it's kind of
obvious the answer
it's because you atheists you're only
tearing things down you're only taking
away the church and the belief you
haven't given them a soft landing you
haven't replaced these social structures
so you know i think that this is just
completely in line with what you just
said but it's always good to emphasize
the constructive part of this very
ambitious program
yeah totally and it's very hard because
i in my experience a lot of people
um
are very worried who theorize in this
domain are worried about making the
positive step because they don't want to
impose their values on others
and
and i think that there's something right
about that we don't want to impose our
values on others but first of all
i think that there's a process of coming
to concretize our values together so
sometimes what we disagree about is not
the high value this is an andersonian
point is not the higher value but how
it's been concretized or operationalized
and so what we need to do is think of
ourselves as not having conflicting
values but maybe
uh different understandings of what the
world is like
um
uh we might have some of us might have
empirically more adequate beliefs than
others and so it's not a disagreement of
values it's a disagreement about the
world and so we have to sort of begin to
resolve some of that and some of it is
that we we share the value but we don't
we don't see how that value is realized
in this other practice and so we have to
reveal to someone how that value is
revealed in a different practice
and that's hard work and it's not always
through argument
sometimes you have to get them to try on
the practice maybe to experiment
yeah you have to sort of embody it to
feel that oh i know i see this is
something that i can do i can believe in
etc but that's hard to get people to do
sure and it takes trust it takes
tremendous trust to move outside your
comfort zone
yeah i mean i get this a lot uh people
ask me as a scientist podcaster etc you
know
like
how can i when i go to visit my family
at thanksgiving how can i make them more
rational how can i make this make them
see true facts and usually my answer is
something along the lines of you know
don't try to argue them into your world
view just
be an exemplar of a successful world
view right like live life be the person
that they would want to be or be friends
with but that brings up i want to re-ask
the question about um or i mean i ask
too many questions at once so let's
let's focus in on the idea of critical
theory uh it's been in the news lately
for not necessarily sensible reasons but
um
number one how do you think of what
critical theory is and number two how
does it fit into this thing i said you
just said which i think is extremely
sensible that we can't ignore the
constructive part we can't we can't
ignore we can't just be critical right
we have to
impose not impose but we have to offer
some alternative ways of living and
being
yeah so
critical theory is a complicated
tradition and there's a a
a european version
of critical the frankfurt school
critical theory in particular french
critical theory and then there's
critical race theory that is more
commonly
um
embraced in the u.s
i see critical theory the commonality
in these different forms of critical
theory
um as being that we start our theorizing
on the ground from within a social
movement
so
you are not trying to be neutral
and
and sort of
do the ideal theory thing come up from a
neutral perspective to what an ideal
would be
you're on the ground looking at
struggles that people are having
in their current situations
um
and and and
and kinds of suffering
that people are facing
and trying to provide tools
for people in those situations um to
articulate the nature of their suffering
and to articulate their complaints
with
the current social formations and the
current structures so the first moment
is negative the first moment is
i can't do this anymore this is like not
okay with me right so for me i mean for
some people it's i can't put up with
uh being oppressed as a person of color
but mine is i can't put up with
oppressing people of color right i mean
so there's come there's both it's not
just one side or the other there's
you know this is things are wrong and i
can't take it anymore and so you you go
into that space
and try to find
ways of articulating
what's wrong why is it wrong what are
alternative paradigms so think of marx
right marx in the working class okay we
have a notion of exploitation the
appropriation of surplus value this was
a theory to try to explain
why there was dissatisfaction and
frustration and misery on the part of
the working class so there is that
negative part of it
and in critical race theory i think that
there is that as well of looking at look
this what is the nature of this
suffering it's not just
uh jim crow and legal segregation it's
deeper than that it has a long history
what is that history what is the social
meaning of blackness how does that
meaning infiltrate our lives and play a
role in our everyday encounters so
there's that kind of
articulation
that the critical theorist offers
but it's also trying to
um
uh
open new possibilities
for
given the paradigm shifts for seeing
different ways of organizing ourselves
organizing ourselves
with different meanings what would the
meaning of whiteness be
if whiteness were not just
you know anglo-christian domination
you know something that what would it be
what is that going to be like um
how were we going to live whiteness or
are we going to give up race entirely
right so those sorts of questions become
and then
for
some of the critical theorists
what you do is you
again
don't go to the high
uh heights you know the upper reaches of
theory
but work collectively on the ground with
people to try and do the work i was
mentioning to do the collective
rethinking of the practices the
collective rethinking of the of the
meanings and the language and the norms
that would get us through that paradigm
shift and i think this is i i hear what
you're saying and i've heard it before
and it does make sense but this is where
i do have worries i think that are that
are non-trivial um
if you to the extent that you say look
you know we talk about the world in a
certain vocabulary we take it for
granted there's a lot of
hidden things going on here that uh some
maybe are useful some maybe you're just
oppressive and bad let's interrogate
them that all sounds good to me but then
uh the tying of it to a
social or even an activist kind of
perspective where you say here's
something wrong about the world and you
know i want to make the world better and
that's informing how i
do this uh rethinking of my categories
uh is that a that doesn't seem like a
necessary connection to me i mean maybe
it's useful maybe it's helpful but i i s
i want to imagine that whether or not i
should have it there is just a
perspective that says
uh
forgetting about what i want the world
to be i want to understand it better i
want to be able to think about it better
and say true things about it whether or
not i'm that interested in going out
there making it a better place you know
how valid is that perspective would you
say
so where you're doing kind of normative
inquiry
but not on the ground
yeah i mean in the ivory tower yeah
no i have no problem with people doing
um ivory tower
work on the normative i think there are
many distinctions that it's important
for us to be able to make
um
you know
that take a rook a lot of work and a lot
of thought to be able to sort out i have
no problem with that
um
it's more a question of
so think of it this way this might work
might not but
when we're reasoning about things we
reason about means to ends and we reason
about ends it's not clear we reason
about ends but we let's say that the
ideal theorist thinks that we're
reasoning about ends about our goals our
objectives the ultimate values
um
i think that there's
that that ivory tower
reasoning
is not always the best at helping us
think about our ends
because understanding our ends
needs to be grounded in
our experience
our history
our
our form of life
um what what uh we have
been raised to value and things like
that it it is very it is very textured
it is very concrete
um i think
now
and but there are lots of questions that
come up
about
you know how what distinctions do we
need to make
when we're articulating those ends or
when we're trying to think about the
means toward those ends and such like
that and i think that that there's a
definitely a place there
for ivory tower work um because
it takes i mean as aristotle would say
it takes leisure to be able to spend a
lot of time thinking about that stuff
and making those distinctions now we
call it work but we also know that it's
really you know kind of
yeah we're lucky we're privileged
it's not work in the sense of real work
anyway but but it's but there's a kind
of
um and i think most cultures have spaces
for people to do this sort of reflection
and clarification and distinction making
it might be in a priesthood it might be
you know in a
uh
spiritual practice of various kinds we
tend to think of and and our
philosophers tend to think that reason
is our spiritual practice i don't think
that's
a good i don't think it is but you know
that's the way some people think of it
um
but i i do think that there's space for
that and a need for that
but but i also think that if it's not
well informed by what people on the
ground are valuing
and what matters to them
and why it matters to them then it can
go really badly astray you know what can
i say but that's a really good answer i
i get it
um
reason is or should be the slave of the
passions in in some sense i i
i've become a moral constructivist in my
middle age and i think that uh like you
put it very well that the
ends are things that are i'm going to
paraphrase because i can't remember
exactly but the ends that we shoot for
are not
purely intellectual constructions right
i mean they come out of how we live who
we are how we were born our genetics for
that matter right who knows and our
environment our environment our friends
sort of what our
your geography is going to be relevant
your and your biology but in your
history i mean all of these things are
going to be super important and to think
that you can sort of come up with a
a picture of how it's all supposed to
work i i think that's really hard
there's one thing to move in a direction
but there's nothing to figure out what
direction you want to move in and these
are you know closely related with
different things to do
and you can help i mean the the the
ivory tower also enables people to
articulate their values and ends
gives them
choices for how to think about it and
this is where the paradigm shifting
comes because sometimes you can think
this is your end but it's a it's a
tangle and you want to go no no it does
you can untangle it and take this and
that could be it would leave that other
baggage alone leave it behind move
forward you know
well good i think maybe then this gives
us a very good place to wrap up with
because i'm interested in someone who
likes interdisciplinary engagement and
thought and so forth
um and is frustrated by our beloved home
the academy and it's in its sort of
inability to
be nimble when thinking about some of
these things uh there was i hope i don't
want to take a quote out of context but
there's a quote in an interview you did
where you mentioned philosophers being
limited in their intelligences
and that plural there is very important
you're not saying that their
intelligence is limited they're very
very smart but they're varieties of
intelligence and believe me physicists
are exactly the same way you can i've
often mentioned how scientists uh in
academia are are in in a very
real sense often anti-intellectual
because when they talk about things that
are not their science they're just not
interested it's just not what they do
and and philosophers i'm sure are the
same way um
what can we do about that should we do
anything about it should we just live
with it just you know sprinkle the
academy with different kinds of
intelligences so that collectively we
get it right or should individuals try
to be a little bit more
uh flexible in these ways
i think that's a a really good good
question and i don't think i have a a
very good answer but
i think that we do need to value
um
different
different contributions to
um philosophy or to intellectual life um
there are
there are
many ways to contribute not just
reasoning not just experimenting etc
like that because
you can bring to
your work social understanding
and emotional understanding and
perceptual acuity
that
that i think often is not well
appreciated
in the academy and as individuals you
can bring that and be allowed to bring
it and you can value it so that there's
a kind of two parts to that one is
we can allow ourselves as individuals to
bring those parts of ourselves into the
academy and value other people bringing
that into the academy we can also value
people who have it when we lack it and
bring them in because they have it they
have emotional intelligence or social
intelligence or perceptual intelligence
so we can value value then bring them in
i don't have it and acknowledge that you
don't have it and you want someone who
has it to bring it in um
but i also think that
we need to think differently about what
we're trying to do in some parts of the
academy
i i think i'm a believer that there's
intrinsic value in knowledge
that we ought to allow people to do
completely esoteric
sort of wild and crazy things for their
own sake because they're of value and i
never want to stand in the way of them
doing it
but i do think that there are
contemporary challenges that require us
to do interdisciplinary work and i it
sounds like you agree that we that you
know solving climate change is not just
an engineering problem
it's a it's a social problem i mean et
cetera et cetera i'd pick any major
challenge
and there's going to
it's going to require
people from different disciplines and
people people with very different intel
intelligences to be involved in it so i
think expanding
uh interdisciplinarity
interdisciplinary programs
interdisciplinary
institutes and such
and i i think it's people downplay how
difficult that is i mean i was a
director of women's and gender studies
at mit for a number of years
and i had to learn
other
how i had to get a feel for different
languages and different methodologies
and different ways of doing things in
order to communicate with my faculty
right because
they weren't communicating with each
other and i wanted to communicate with
all of them and such and it's very hard
and it's very time consuming but we're
not
we're not really rewarded uh for doing
that um
and we're not so just even recently um i
was told that one of my
interdisciplinary courses wouldn't count
toward
a distribution requirement in philosophy
and it blew my mind it blew my mind
because
i was thinking that this is like
so deeply philosophical to be engaged in
the
in this conversation um i i got them to
change their mind so it became
uh but it's but it's that sort of
expectation the
the gate posts of the disciplines that
are are so often
um
uh locked
and i think that we should be moving in
that direction as well i mean that that
would be a really good place to end
except that you brought something else
up that i have to follow up on when you
mention you know climate change and the
in the i think of the interdisciplinary
impulse you know
again at the purely ivory tower level
but but it's even more crucial when it
comes to saving the world and and oh
totally uh climate change is one of them
but also the future of democracy is the
other one that is an obvious thing that
we worry about so maybe i'll give you a
chance to say some words about that
especially in the context of
this tipping point that you and your
friends and i count myself among them
want to bring about where we're changing
society radically and and
this i'm sure that as good as it is it
feeds into polarization right i mean
there's a whole half of the country that
reacts against it and this is why
critical race theory is in the news
because not because of critical race
theory but because it's a symbol to
react against and and you know we're
trying to make the world a better place
but also giving ammunition to those who
want to resist it and that's a tricky
thing to negotiate in a democracy
yes definitely it is um
so i think that
oftentimes
um people i talk to they want an answer
and they want it now
and because things aren't going so well
um
and
and i think that
that that's
not possible
to have an answer and to have it now
i think that we have to see ourselves as
part of a very long-term process
and we may be
in
a really
conflict
uh prone
moment
in that process
um and the process may go very wrong
but we can't control it right
we're
if we're not nobody is in control to be
honest right it is a social process
which like a natural process has its own
forces that are working that none of us
have the levers to manage or manipulate
uh societies are complex dynamic systems
right they are they're not
nobody has control of them
and
and there are things that we can do
small things often collections of small
things many you know many many small
things
but um
even coming up with the answer of how it
should happen won't make it happen
right and so and so we have to
throw ourselves into it
with some hope
and
humility
and
do what we can
okay that's the perfect place to end i
think i think you summed it up very very
well doing what we can open humility
sally hassling here thanks so much for
being on the windscape podcast
thank you so much it was really a
pleasure i enjoyed it and uh found you a
very stimulating conversation partners
oh thank you i hope there'll be other
times when we can talk uh podcast or not
there should be thanks very much
[Music]
you